- Kherson est occupée par
les Russes depuis le 2 mars,
mais les habitants continuent
à résister et à protester,
défiant carrément les soldats.
tau se resserre et ceux
qui le peuvent tentent de fuir.
C'est le cas de Salva Boo,
un jeuneun jeuneun jeune comédit
tout juste d'arriver à Kiev.
Pas facile : il faut contourner;
un voyage infernal.
"Les innombrables contrôles
sont sévères; parfois, il fautgs
russes pour passer."
Slava est comédien.
Dans son spectacle comique,
il fait des blagues sur Poutine
et les soldats russes :
il valait donc mieux partir.
Comme c'est le cas d'Anastasia,
qui veut taire son nom parce que
ses parents sont restés là-bas.
- Ils ont commencé à nous
questionner : qui vous êtes,
est-ce que vous êtes
journalistes, etc.
Puis, ils regardaient que
nous écrivons quelque chose
comme "scomme "scomme "scomme "t
dire "vive l'Ukraine", "glory to
Ukraine" et ils disent :
"Pourquoi tu l'as écrit?
Est-ce que tu es nazie?
Pourquoi il y a des blagues
sur les Russes?"
- Comme Slava, Anastasia a
le russe comme langue maternelle
mais elle se sent ukrainienne.
- 100 % ukrainienne, oui.
- Très vite, les Russes
ont coupé toute communication
avec l'Ukraine; la population
s'est retrouvée en situation
de pénurie, à faire la queue
pour tout, comme à l'époque
soviétique. Très peu d'images
ont pu sortir de Kherson.
Celles des manifestations ont
impressionné le monde entier.
"Au début, il y avait des
manifestations tous les jours,
dit Slava, puis, c'est devenu
trop dangereux. L'armée a été
remplacée par la milice
et la répression est devenue
violente."
(explosion et tirs)
- Je sentais beaucoup
d'oppression; au début de
la guerre, j'ai même changé,
j'ai commencé à parler ukrainien
parce qu'avant je parlais russe.
Mais après qu'ils sont arrivés
à ma maison, j'avais très peur,
j'ai recommencé à parler russe
parce que c'est vraiment
dangereux : tu ne sais jamais
ce qui se passe dans leur tête.
- "Les Russes traquent
les activistes, les vétérans
de l'armée ukrainienne.
Ils cherchent ceux
qu'ils appellent les nazis,
inspectent les tatouages."
- Il y a beaucoup d'activistes
et des politiciens, et il y a
des journalistes qui sont
disparus à Kherson et
on ne sait pas où ils sont.
Soit qu'ils sont déportés,
soit qu'ils sont questionnés
dans quelque prison
ou même tués.
- À Kiev, Slava donne
des spectacles comiques pour
lever des fonds pour l'armée
ukrainienne.
Anastasia est arrivée à Odessa
il y a deux jours.
- Quand j'ai vu la résistance
aïv et aïv et aïv et aïv et aïï,
maintenant, je me sens très
en sécurité ici, à Odessa,(-eé .
- Mykolaïv, sur la routevers Od.
À partir de Kherson, les Russes
veulent absolument la capturer,
car elle est la clé de
la conquête du port d'Odessaau r
Noire, le joyau et le poumon
économique dont l'Ukraine
ne peut pas se passer.
Jean-Michel Leprince,
Radio-Canada, Kie